it's January 2025 you get sworn in what
is top of the list in terms of the
things that you want to express or get
done let me start with the most
important which is how I will lead and
I'm going to lead very differently I'm
going to have a Team of Rivals in the
White House Andrew uh not unlike Abraham
Lincoln put together uh in the 1860s
during the worst crisis in American
history to that point the Civil War I'll
also have a youth cabinet it's time to
bring young people's voices into the
White House a delegate from every one of
the 50 states come up with great ideas
about social media regulation about uh
the future of AI both the blessings and
the curses climate change gun violence
prevention the things that young people
are most focused on for good reason the
current generation of leaders have got
to be replaced with Next Generation
leaders who understand what's coming who
have a different worldview different
competencies and most of all are ready
to work together to solve problems stop
fighting each other and start fighting
for each other